c'è qualcuno qua ho sentito un rumore
strano mi sembrano giu o no oggi nuovo
episodio monga nella vita reale del re
con dinho oggi io sono i primi menta
ragione io la cosa non ti piace più
nuovo cappello monga delle corna sono
uguali a quelli diavolo infatti con
queste forme e rappresenta proprio il
mio segno zodiacale
prima del mio studio oggi ci saranno
delle nuove regole plurale perché avremo
il telecomando con cui possiamo mette
prosa riavvolgere mettere muto in potrà
utilizzare il telecomando
chi vince i round potrà utilizzare il
telecomando è abbiamo delle nuovissime
mystery begin con tante sorprese dentro
chi vince potrà aprire nomi dei big
anche voi avrete sel e caos perché anche
voi e alla fine del video scoprirete
avete vinto o se avete perso quindi
mettetevi comodi lasciate un bel mi
piace è iniziamo con il primo rate se
non vita di gesù integrano i bastoni
per vincere la partita e crew mez non
devono farsi trovare devono tornare qua
nella cameretta è cambiare il colore
della lampada crew mail nel proprio
colore da trio wade se ci riescono senza
essere presi dall'impostare hanno vinto
il turno becca per primo il nostro
strumento e berlino by merlino pesca
vediamo un po berlino berlino è crollato
senza perdere peso berlino ha pescato
chiumenti impostore è questo quello che
doveva essere più mesi comunque conta il
primo che ha pescato e cioè crisi
ok per cui gli imputo
sei pronto anche questo vuol dire che io
sono a scappare
bene se diamo la nostra arma da
impostore
in gergo il martello
siamo a cercare crew mei dove sempre
nascosto viola secondo me qua al
reattore
non c'è nessuno
[Musica]
allora credo che l'impostore sia fuori
meglio se trovo un nascondino qui a
un'idea e un po estrema ma proviamoci
mettiamo non mi tornerà mai qui sopra
non ce la faccio ad andare più avanti
aiuto mi mando tutti o qualcuno qua un
rumore strano c'è nessuno qua tanto da
qui non riesce a perdermi neanche questo
[Risate]
stadio ed ho vinto io
ho vinto il primo round
ora posso scegliere la meester ita è che
il gol ha viste di ben nota vediamo che
sei destra un mini astuccio sailor moon
anche se ci sta tipo solo una matita va
dentro appresso per carino perché è rosa
e glitterato poi c'è un'altra cosa
miti ma questa è di nightmare before
christmas contento dei miei film
preferiti lo conoscete scrivete nei
commenti se la fra 7 potrebbe capitarmi
uno di questi personaggi io spero che mi
capiti jack vediamo e sarà capitan luca
milano e il mio caffè noto petit che io
adoro le cose paurose le cose di
halloween
mi piace zac bellissima
prima test turbo e lascia più mi piace
entro tre secondi 3 2
a completare la prima tac viola mi ha
rubato il cappello corna e allora
fareste io questa volta
si no
siccome io ho vinto lo scorso turno
posso utilizzare il telecomando wii 2
fiume avuto un'idea 8 9 10
ma diamo scegliere l'arma quindi arma
scegliamo questa volta io ho scelto la
mia arma presenta andiamo a prenderli
cos'era ragazzi ho in mente un
nascondiglio fantastico mi nasconderò
dentro a questa festa è il merlino tu
non devi svelare il mio nascondiglio ok
cui rubarmi il largo ghiglia berlino
l'ho trovato prima io e poi tu non c
entri dentro france
ora proviamo a tornare in chiave rezza e
merlino marino è un po preoccupata in
vado
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questa cosa e su pastrana andiamo a
controllare le età ea di lino questo
bidone ma no aspetto il secondo poi c'è
qualcosa di strano
questa piccola alla grande alle scarpe
come è possibile lanciare mi sono
dimenticata a vitale in pausa play
grazie al telecomando ho vinto anche
questa round così forte che non ti sei
accorto prima di lui nascosto nel
leggere le storie del relatore
elga la mistery bag argento mi sembra di
vedere che c'è un campo
[Musica]
ma che solo lascia adesso posso andare a
tagliare la legna vietata a berlino come
sempre è terzo in ultim'ora lascia la
[Musica]
sapete che berlino le trecce e parte
guerra berlino vorrebbe il mio cappello
ma non posso darglielo perché sono se lo
mangiano vecchio nascondiglio e cioè ti
ricordi la casetta
vi ricordate cui l'adc a testa ai
abbiamo di starci sette giocatori di un
certo che ci stiamo stretto non rimanere
incastrata oh mi raccomando
siamo ben nascosti ecco noi lazio umano
porta
speriamo che non si veda qui
[Applauso]
ovviamente berlino ha vinto perché è
bravissimo giocare a nascondino
ed ecco una vita di beck giallo per
merlino colle gord merli è felicissimo
per il nuovo zucchino parrocchietta
rosicchiare
[Musica]
4 il pastore
ciao ragazzi mi escono quel giardino non
mi troverò mai forse ma ho scelto il
nerf costate un po guardatevi c'è là
fuori c'è qualcuno che si sta
nascondendo il giardino sapete il ferito
è un'idea altra il nervo credo che
utilizzano ancora il binocolo a bada una
volta girato dall'altra no andrò al
piano di sopra infatti letali potrò
vedere dove si nasconde l'anima per
colpirlo dall'alto
sono qui in terrazzo vediamo a vi vedo
troppo vicino così vediamo dove anita mi
sembra laggiù si sta nascondendo sta
cercando un nascondiglio dove sta
andando
ora aprendo o no
mi hai conosciuto è proprio lì mi sa che
mi sta spiando già sopra al terrazzo
posso andare a cambiare il colore della
l'altro da creme italiano visto che lui
dal piano di sopra o no si è accorta che
sono qui sta andando in camera a
cambiare il colore della lampada andiamo
speriamo ci sono arrivato prima io mi
avvolge
apriamo l'ultima mystery back la mia
mister in back bling avesse già un po di
dentro c'è un cappellino per parlarti di
harry potter dicevamo dunque non è una
giacchetta questo è il gelato al
cioccolato perderà www c'è qualcosa ma
troppo dentro
[Applauso]
[Musica]
siccome tu l'altra volta hai già aperto
questo e sai come funziona lo regalo a
te sei contento grazie imbrogliate per
natale non ho imbrogliato roberto qui
per voi in quale altro video aperto un
personaggio di questi di harry potter e
che personaggio mi è capitato e diamo
che risponde correttamente nei
commentero che mi capiti r
hermione o draco vediamo apriamo la
prima casellina è provate a indovinare
il personaggio prima di aprire il
personaggio visto che ci sono tutti gli
indizi allora questo devo mettere il
dito sopra verde mi sembra che sia verde
quindi potrebbe essere o drago piton
insomma serpeverde numero due
abbiamo un incantesimo scritto di vinto
forse potrebbe davvero essere il drago
come il bravo a dovrebbe esserci la
bacchetta e questa bacchetta prossimo
indizio
abbiamo una pergamena chiusa produttivo
inizio questo un piattino con una tazza
non riesco a capire chi può essere
questo personaggio voi siete riusciti a
dominarlo ora passiamo la creatura
magica che è carino berlino serbe verde
rea corvo nero questo è ciò anche con il
gruppetto e la pergamena che carina
prima rete scriveteci nei commenti quali
mistery box mi è piaciuta più di tutti i
quali sorpreso mi è piaciuta fin tutti
se volete vedere altri video con le
mistery box ultimo al traffico per voi
cliccare in una di queste quattro
cartellini dei fatti anche questa tasca
avrete vinto la challenge anche su
quella che preferite buona reazione
ciao